now as we've been discussing this
morning the reason the chancellor's in
such trouble over his family's tax and
residence arrangement
is how all this looks at a time when so
many people's finances are being
squeezed sometimes by decisions he
himself is taking
ad work benefits will rise by a little
over three percent tomorrow whilst
inflation is heading north of eight
percent that's a very significant cut in
income and living standards for some of
the uh those on the lowest incomes in
the country in fact the joseph rowntree
foundation says it will be the greatest
fall in the value of basic rate of
out-of-work benefits in 50 years
joseph roundry foundation director helen
barnard joins me now
good morning mrs barnard um
why do you say this is the biggest fall
uh in such a long period
what we've seen obviously is for a
decade we've had cuts and freezes to
benefits and actually for eight of the
last 10 years the benefits have been
losing value
so we're already at a historic low
now because although benefits go up
tomorrow they go up by so much less than
the cost of living is rising
it means that in terms of their value so
how much bread and milk you can buy in
the shops it is the biggest fall in
value since 1972 for 50 years
and obviously people are already very
often in quite desperate situations they
are struggling to afford food and
heating and basic hygiene products
and now the government is imposing this
enormous cut
probably at the worst possible time
given how difficult things are out there
in the country
uh from your research what what um
can you describe the real world impact
of this to some of the families that
you've talked to
i mean we're seeing things like
pensioners riding the buses all day to
keep warm we're seeing children who are
using a torch at night because even at
age six they know their parents can't
afford to turn the lights on all the
time
we've heard from food banks who are
saying look please don't donate fresh
food because the people we're helping
can't afford to plug the fridge in let
alone cook food
there was a story the other day about a
young man a teenager fainting at a food
bank because he hadn't eaten enough in
the run-up
and actually we're seeing this spread so
people who have been donating and
volunteering for years
are actually having to say at the end of
their shift have we got any left over
because i can't afford to eat properly
anymore
i don't know if you had the chance to
listen to um the crime policing minister
kit malthouse when i spoke to him about
what 45 minutes ago and asked him about
this and he said that
in essence the government had no choice
after
covered and the amount was spent there
the uncertainties for the public
finances uh engendered by the conflict
uh in ukraine um
what's your answer to
that uh case
i think if you look at the spring
statement the chancellor spent about 18
billion pounds that's the money that he
decided he could afford to spend he
probably could have spent more and still
stayed within his rules but let's just
take the 18 billion
of that money about two-thirds went to
benefit people in the richest half of
the country
so he actually had the money the issue
is that the government is not
prioritizing using the money they have
to protect the poorest people who are
facing the greatest hardship
your report today is about people who
are dependent on benefits but um the
squeeze isn't just facing those people i
think um people in work are also facing
uh some uh drop in their living
standards um
what what does uh your organization
uh think is going to happen to those in
work and what the what will be the
impact on them
of course many people at work also get
benefits to top up low earnings so this
squeeze on benefits actually affects a
lot of low-income workers as well as
people who can't work because they are
disabled or they're caring for small
children or they're caring for adults so
actually workers are going to feel this
and of course it's this kind of irony
that even where you have something like
raising the national insurance threshold
which helps some not all but some
low-income workers
people who are earning little enough
that they get topped up by benefit
system actually lose a lot of the
benefit of something like that
because their benefits get pulled away
to make up for the fact that they're
keeping a bit more of their income
so actually low-income workers
are facing incredibly difficult
situations
and you know we know the majority of
people in poverty now are in working
households one of the problems is that
too many jobs are not just low paid but
they're insecure you know you don't know
what money you're getting one week to
the next you don't get sick pay
you don't get protection if something
goes wrong
and so it is people who are really
vulnerable in that situation when
they're working who are also now
struggling to afford you know the basic
essentials and having to rely on
charities or you know toothpaste and
toilet roll and you know it it's
humiliating for a lot of people you know
wonderful as it is that people are
helping
to know that even if you're working two
jobs you still can't afford to turn your
heating on or by your child a pair of
shoes that fit them that's not a
situation anyone should be in
helen barnard thank you very much for
your time this morning